It was a stage fit for the coronation of an emperor...
...and for Samsung, that was in effect what Lee Kun-hee would become.
On his father's death in 1987, Lee took the helm of a business...
...that he would turn into South Korea's dominant family conglomerate or chaebol.
He focused on increasing the ambition of the electronics arm,...
...famously urging his staff to "change everything except your wives and children."
The company was able to take this vision and able to dole it out into, you could say,....
...ideological tracks that they would hand out to employees...
...and that employees would study.
They would read his words like they were literally a page out of the Bible.
And there was an almost religious fervor to the public destruction...
...he ordered of defective phones in 1995.
The call to innovation and higher valued products...
...transforms Samsung into the global giant it is today.
In South Korea, the sprawling network of Samsung businesses...
...covers everything from ship building to life insurance,...
...construction to credit cards.
The group's revenues are equivalent to 20% of South Korea's GDP.
In 2014, he suffered a major heart attack.
He spent the rest of his life in a Samsung hospital.
The empire now rests on the shoulders of Lee's son, Jae-yong, also known as Jay Y. Lee.